development
let me remind you that executive vice
president valerie stombrowskis
and commissioner janusz wojciechowski
will come down to the press room after
this midday briefing for a press
conference
on trade and agriculture
and with that we have finished our
announcements
and i passed the floor to
[Music]
thomas thomas you have the floor
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
g
[Music]
oh sorry marquetta
uh do you hear me yes i do hear you
yeah hi okay uh thank you very much for
the question i'm from dunigan from the
czech republic from prague i have a
question
concerning uh concerning the number of
the vials
in uh pfizer bioentech vaccines uh
because after the ruling
of the ema uh there's possibility or the
the six vials can can be extracted from
one vial
so as i understand it correctly now that
the company pfizer bioentec
that they are delivering now the doses
to each
countries according to those six number
six
six doses so um is it is it like now uh
what is going to happen in the future
that always that will be
the number of deliveries uh uh according
to the
six doses in one while
thank you that's not really a question
on the double speech
that the president has just given but i
understand that the interest of course
is focused on
on the health related questions so i
will pass the floor
on this to stefan
um thank you very much yes indeed emma
has uh issued
some time ago a recommendation regarding
the issue of extracting six
dose from these vials our understanding
is
that thanks to the extraction of the
sixth the first thing i have to stress
though is that
our agreements have been concluded in
the context of
numbers of doses this is what has to be
delivered and this is also what is
expected from the company
our understanding is that thanks to the
delivery of thanks to the possibility to
extract assist
those um the
the the deliveries can take place more
quickly so
an acceleration of delivery so i think
that is that is good
this being said it is important as you
know that you have
the appropriate material to do this
syringes and needles that allow to
extract
the sixth dose for this the commission
has launched a joint procurement and has
concluded
framework contracts which allow member
states
now already to purchase such materials
thank you thank you other other
questions
for us today on vaccines
jacob
will this enter into force and uh
beginning of yourself hi again
can you hear me now yes yes okay my
question is on the
export authorization scheme for vaccine
when this will enter into force and
whether the safeguard committee has to
vote on it
and when this would be
thank you to stefan on this
thank you very much you see me and you
hear me yeah
thank you very much indeed this export
registration mechanism has been
announced by commissioner k aquidus
yesterday
the idea is to set up a system that
allows to ensure
transparency about the vaccines that
have been produced in the european union
and that would
be exported so in the interest of
transparency also taking into account
the fact that the european union has
invested quite important sums
in the development of production
capacity in the european union
and then in order to ensure the
transparency of
this of what is happening with vaccines
produced here
this mechanism has been proposed the
commission is now working
uh towards uh the development of this
mechanism
and we hope to have more information by
the end
of the week on this thank you
thank you jacob you have a follow-up
exactly is the commission working and i
don't understand because
if if i understand this correctly it
would be the same mechanism that was
also imposed on masks
last year so just an implementing
regulation
um where basically i think last time
around it took one day to adopt this
by a vote in the committee so maybe if
you can explain a bit more the process
and what the commission is
proposing exactly and whether this
differs from
the scheme that was imposed on masks
last year stefan
thank you very much well the practical
details of the system still have to be
worked out that's the first thing i want
to say i want to reiterate what i said
before that the
the purpose of this mechanism will be to
ensure transparency
regarding production of vaccines in the
european union but again
the the operational aspects the
operational arrangements to set this up
have to be worked out how it will be
organized which form it will take
and so on this is what the commission is
working on
and as i said on the base of this work
we will
we're working towards a proposal for
this instrument by
the end of this week but again the
practical arrangements have to be
worked on thank you so jacob watch this
space we'll
be coming back with further details um
later on
um let's continue on the issue of
vaccines
stephan
well um i think you can only confirm
what i said before we are working on our
proposal and
hope to have this proposal towards the
end of the week that's the idea so
that's the deadline that the timing on
the base of which we are working
what i would like to add and and i think
it's the reiteration of what i said
before
it is meant to be a transparency
instrument a notification instrument
uh companies that want to export
vexies are invited or will be requested
rather to
inform to notify the authorities of this
intention to export these products
this is based on the idea that the
european commission has spent quite a
lot of funds
in the development of these production
capacities to make sure that there is
sufficient doses available for the
european
uh union and beyond and it's in order to
assess this commitment contractual
arrangements that this
monitoring system has been set up
and i think i'll have to leave it at
that for a time being
thank you matisse
yeah i do have a follow-up question on
this because the way it was presented
yesterday this instrument i thought it
was requirements on companies
more than a request and now so i was
waiting uh
wondering what would be the legal basis
for a requirement like this which hasn't
been part of the original contract
and what would be the situation if the
commission
doesn't like the export plans that
will be given as a notice of what can
the commission do in that case
stefan
i'm sorry but i think there's really not
a lot i can add
what i've expected i've explained in the
principle the objective
why we are doing this put in the context
of our vaccinations
vaccination strategy and the
establishment of this diverse portfolio
and the deployment of these vaccines
we commissioner has announced this
mechanism yesterday to achieve or to
work towards the
priorities and objectives that they have
just explained but
forgive me that if i do i'm not yet in a
position to explain all the practical
arrangements and the practical
operational setup of this system this is
something we are working on and as i
said
by the end of the week uh we we should
have
this um ready and we'll be in a position
to say more i think
let me just emphasize the word uh
that is important here is transparency
this is not about blocking this is about
knowing what the companies
are exporting or will export to markets
outside
of the european uh union
apologies it's not based on
it's not related to the contracts per se
this is something
which the european union can of course
implement and as was mentioned before we
have already done this in other
in other contexts and it allows public
authorities
and the public to know what
exports are taking place um from
companies producing within the
within the european union and we will
come back with the exact implementation
details
um at a later stage apologies raf
yes hi uh good morning i have the two
simple questions uh
uh also on this uh just just to get back
uh on
on pfizer i just want to have an update
how are we doing
we were supposed to come back to 100
percent uh this week
to and then start with uh more to uh
compensate for the previous losses later
uh
stefan do we have 100 do we have
indications that we will have 100
this week and then i have a second
question on the
pandemic itself uh portugal
is in a very bad state as it is and
there is talk that they will cons
that they will ask for help to the
european union
uh one question is has uh portugal
already asked
for help and the and then a theoretical
question
if they ask for help how will this be
through what institutional ways will
that be processed
thank you sorry ralph help on what
to deal with the overflow of hospitals
in that sense and with the specific
pandemic issues that are at hand
these days okay stefan on the first
question
thank you very much as far as faisal is
concerned indeed the company had
announced as you know that
last week there would be problems with
the deliveries or the deliveries of the
vaccines and that
in this week it would take up and go
again to the 100
of the deliveries we are following this
we're keeping an eye on this the week is
not yet over yet of course so
the 100 is expected to be delivered
by the end of this week um together this
week
and last week for this week and last
week this would mean that
quite a lot of what was supposed to be
delivered will be delivered
and so we continue to monitor this
and to check that indeed the engagement
the commitment the company has taken
is taking place but we're still in the
beginning of the week of course
and on the second question um because
i'm not aware of the details of the
portuguese request
stefan we have inspirations on your side
um i have to say that i'm not aware of
any requests in this regard
maybe also good to check with the with
the portuguese authorities
of course if your request comes we will
look into it that is for sure but i
don't think i can give
any further details at this moment thank
you let me remind you ralph that
a lot has already been done by the
european union in order to
assist member states in facing
the different challenges urgencies
emergencies
that stem from the from the crisis
notably
by flexibilizing as much as possible the
use
of the of the european budget this was a
famous
um which allowed them to reallocate uh
funds notably from the from the
structural funds we also have of course
the mechanisms under the civil
protection mechanism but we would need
to
know more on the specific requests from
the portuguese authorities
to to be able to answer more precisely
of course
stefa stefano said if a request comes
the commission
will will analyze it as swiftly as
possible taking into account
its prerogatives and the means at its
disposal
we continue with vaccines lisa
yes hello can you hear me yes go ahead
okay great
i have three questions if i may the
first two is regarding uh estra seneca
on the topic of this sudden decline in
the doses from
astrazeneca um i wonder what what is the
exact information that
that you are not getting from the
company
in terms of why why why do we have this
decline
and the second question is um do you
have reason to suspect
that astrazeneca has sold vaccines to
other countries outside of the eu
that should have been reserved for the
eu
if we can start with those questions
please stephan
thank you very much thank you very much
luis for these questions
um listen we're not going to have a
debate here about all the things that
astrazeneca has said or has not said
with regard to
issues they may have with deliveries or
no deliveries issues that may that they
may have
or not have with regard to production
capacities what is important i think is
what
the commissioner has stressed yesterday
at the press statement that it's
important
that we have timely deliveries of the
doses of the vaccines that have been
agreed upon
with the company this is important we
are facing a pandemic
and the member states need these doses
so we are having
we had discussions yesterday with the
company as you know
we will now have discussions with the
company again wednesday
um to to continue the discussions on
these deliveries where we will insist as
i said on
timely delivery of the doors in the
interest of the european citizens
um do we have reasons to suspect that
the deliveries have been made to uh to
other countries well um i think
um the commissioner has yesterday
clearly explained
that um there was a dissatisfaction with
the the deliveries as was announced by
the company
and the commissioner has also and we've
already had the opportunity to talk
about this
announce the use of a mechanism that
allows to introduce
more transparency into the system
transparency
regarding doses that have been produced
here in the european union in plants
in factories with with the support of
the european union and european union
budget
so it's important that to build our
contractual relationship of trust we
have the transparency
about element about vaccines that have
been
produced and delivered here in the
european union and how
they have been delivered to other places
in the european union or in the world
thank you the the president made this
uh abundantly clear in her speech in
davos
for the davos forum um this this morning
she uh she reminded everyone that europe
has invested billions
um to help develop the first kovid 19
vaccines the world's first kovid 19
vaccines
we are playing our part to create a
truly
common good and so now the companies
that we have supported that we have
invested in
must deliver they must honor
their obligations that's why we are
setting up
a vaccine export transparency mechanism
to make sure
that we know where the vaccines produced
in europe are going
of course we are determined to
contribute globally
to resolving this pandemic but we also
mean business
when it comes to europe and as you have
seen
we have now very very regular
steering board meetings where we invite
the companies to come
and to and to explain and to work with
us
on ways to ensure that we get the doses
that are required in europe
as quickly as possible and commensurate
to the significant financial
effort that we have made in order for
this to happen
virena sorry you had a third
you had a third question i think is it
on this i guess lisa or on the health
related issue yes
yes thank you for for getting back i
just wanted some verification on the
astrazeneca first
but i will continue to my third question
um because today it
emerged that sweden's health agencies
had
passed the vaccine payments to pfizer
because they want some clarification on
the amount of doses that is
uh that can be uh you know uh
extracted from from the vials uh
so i wonder how how is this going to um
to influence the payments of of the
doses
because obviously some countries are not
able to extract
six doses um you mentioned before that
that you are looking into procurement
of um of equipment
to to be able to do so but at the moment
that
what is the issue around uh around this
payment because
as i understand it this this extra
payment will
will will hit some countries harder um
so how are you going to um to
what are you going to say to the eu
countries how are we going to
to handle uh this uh this situation
thank you sorry
i'm not quite sure i understand your
question
are you saying that sweden has announced
that it is suspending
payments on the basis of the order forms
that it placed
with the company to get doses because in
that case it's
uh it's sweden uh stopping a payment
to the company it does not concern other
eu countries or there's something that i
don't understand apologies
lisa press speak haven't said that in a
while
yeah can you hear me yes go ahead yeah
good okay
uh no well it has come out today and
that that sweden's health agency has
passed the vaccine
payments divisor because they want
clarification on on the amount of doses
in that is you know that can be
extracted in each vial
um and so i wonder some countries can
indeed extract six doses but pfizer now
once wants payment for six doses uh
so that will entail that some countries
uh will pay
more for for the five doses that they
are able to
to extract um
and and so if if that's the case uh
if a country only can extract five doses
well then it has received fewer doses
for the same price
you you understand what i'm what i'm
saying yes i understand so it's not
linked to sweden's payment
it's whether other member states who you
believe have difficulties
or or reporting difficulties in
extracting the six dollars yes indeed
because
okay yes i get it because it will entail
a an extra
an extra payment for the eu countries um
and so
in the end a larger bill so
let me remind you that the uh the indeed
it is the member states who place the
orders
uh with the different pharmaceutical
companies
in this case pfizer on the basis of the
overall agreement
um that we have so then there is a
contractual relationship
between the member state and the company
and therefore it is at that level
that the uh discussions must take place
on the sort of issue that you are uh
that you are mentioning
but i go to stefan in case he wants to
add something
yeah thank you very much eric i think
you're totally right i wanted to add
what i said before the the fact that the
agreements are all
uh complete on the basis of doses so on
those are is what the company has to
deliver that's one thing
second with regards to the extraction of
a sixth
dose as i explained before we have
framework contracts with um providers of
syringes and needles several hundreds of
millions of them
that can be used for the extraction of a
six dose
so this frame these framework contracts
are out there member states can place
their order
at any time to have the necessary
material
um and so the european commission i
think has
taken the necessary steps to make sure
that such material
is available and help member states with
the extraction of six dose thank you
thank you move to bruno
we could see you bruno but you've
disappeared again
i'm here all right go ahead all right go
ahead
um i just wanted to um ask um
a bit more of the detail in terms of the
the the um um register yen span this
morning on ard made it
pretty clear that this is not just about
transparency it's about export
um a restriction he said it would mean
that vaccines
that leave the eu need a permit
can you just tell us more about the
thinking it certainly seems to go beyond
transparency in the minds of the german
health minister
and what's what's your view is it
literally just going to be about a
registered transparency
or could it leave uh two restrictions in
terms of astrazeneca
and the specifics um some of the early
doses
used in the united kingdom were made in
the netherlands
uh and germany is the commission saying
that those
shipments should not have taken
uh place given astrazeneca's
announcement
uh last week and just more generally
um how worried are you about the very
very low rate
of vaccinations across the european um
union at the moment it's just under two
percent i've
i think two percent of uh
uh people compared to ten and a half
percent in the uk for example much much
higher
um israel how concerned are you about
that
and presumably it's not actually because
of shortages
of vaccines at this stage thanks thank
you stefan
thank you very much for these questions
uh bruno
first on the first question on the fact
whether we are going to block exports or
whatever
listen um the main point of entry here
lyric has expanded quite well is
transparency we have finance in we have
financed large amounts in the production
capacity of these companies
we expect a lot from the companies we
expect that these companies
as soon as they have the green light
from emma and the authorization of the
commission
that they're in the capacity that have
the possibility to produce
tens even hundreds of millions of
dollars quickly
this requires serious investments in
production capacity
and this is an important risk and the
commission has taken
part of this risk on itself to make sure
that such capacity is there
so this is a very important investment
which has been made
this on so it is very normal it's very
reasonable
that the commission can follow can
monitor
um what has been done with the doses
what is being done with the doses that
have been produced
using exactly these production
capacities financed by the european
union and that's the idea
to follow to monitor the um
the vaccines that have been produced
that's
the first question i think the second
question um
about astrazeneca uh early doses in the
uk
sent to the uk made from netherlands and
and germany um again
we're not going to talk here uh in in
the press room about
um what astrazeneca um
i think it's very clear the point that
we have made with regard to the
importance of timely deliveries
and the commissioner has also insisted
on this
um creation of this mechanism this
transparency
tool which will allow to much better
monitor and follow what is
going on this is important for the
contractual relationship
that we have with the vaccines
developers and to build a relation of
trust how worried are we about the state
of vaccinations well
we are worried that is for sure this is
a very um we are dealing with a
very important pandemic a vaccination is
very important this is one of the
reasons why
last week the commission came out with
this communication on
establishing a united front against
corvit in this
recommendation um as are in this
communication as you will see
there is a list of many measures and
recommendations from the commission to
the member states
so that together we can handle uh this
pandemic and get as quickly as we can
out of this pandemic
marvel things by the vaccination it's
not just
enough to have vaccines the vaccination
is of course
the one step that is so important to get
us out of the pandemic so this is a very
important issue
an issue that concerns all of us member
states commission and we have to get out
of this
as quickly as possible thank you
lawrence
lawrence you have the floor
can you hear me can you hear me yes we
can hear you
great excellent sorry having some kind
of technical difficulty
uh thanks eric and um so a couple of
questions look
um it can i know i know
you're not getting into the ins and outs
of of the discussion with astrazeneca
but can you at least give us clarity on
one point
is this believed to be a one-off the
problem that they had that set off
um these delays or is this a
problem that could be uh could repeat
itself in the future
in particular um the idea that they
themselves are struggling
to get hold of some uh key ingredients
the the api uh for their vaccines
and secondly he just don't give us a
very clear straight answer to a
to a to a clearage question which is
is the legal protection the legal right
that the
the commission has um with astrazeneca
in terms of the security of supply
similar
to the legal rights we have with the
kurovac contract
thanks thank you on your first point i
can only repeat
what um what stefan has um
has said and that is
that we at this point in time do not
have
the information from the company that we
believe allows us to answer
the question that you are uh you are
asking and indeed we would very much
like
to have this information which is why um
we have invited astrazeneca once again
to a steering board meeting on wednesday
so it's not
that we are unwilling to provide an
explanation it is that we are trying
ourselves
to understand what is the issue we see
that
uh doses are being delivered elsewhere
and we know that we have signed
an agreement with astrazeneca in august
that member states placed their orders i
believe around
october and that we are now
end of january and therefore we believe
that
the doses should be basically um
available to be delivered if
and when the conditional marketing
authorization
um is uh recommended by the european
medicine agency so this is a developing
dialogue that we have
with uh with astrazeneca on your second
question i'm afraid it's not that
straightforward
yes the curvac contract has been made
available in redacted form to to the
european parliament but it is not the
case
for the other contract so we will not
comment on this
at this stage james
is for any uh daily mail i don't know if
you can hear me
go ahead james thanks very much
um yeah so two questions if i could and
i'm sorry i'm going to come back on this
mechanism because you did
announce it last night a transparency
register okay
but if you don't like what you see on
that transparency register
what in very practical and simple terms
can the european commission
do please that is quite important and
then the president of south africa
uh spoke in davos this morning um before
uh wanderline and he accused rich
countries of hoarding
vaccines i'm just wondering is vaccine
nationalism okay
when it comes wrapped in an eu flag
thank you
thank you james on your first question
the point is that we
want to know prior to exports where
exports are going to
um are going to uh to take place that is
what we have announced
yesterday and that is what we will
propose
and this is
what we can say on this at this point in
time
you cannot basically devise strategies
if you don't know what's happening
so in a field which is absolutely
crucial
we are ensuring that we are going to
know exactly what is happening from an
industrial point of view
and as the president has said herself in
davos this morning
because we mean business and because it
is important for us to ensure
that um things are ruled out as we have
agreed
with uh with the companies that is the
sense of the proposal for
um for details as i have said we will
come back
um we will come back uh later
on the second issue in terms of vaccine
nationalism let me just point out
once again that your european commission
was one of the key promoters and indeed
the biggest financial
donor to the kovacs facility so
um if there is one continent which is
playing its role
as far as it can in terms of ensuring
that companies
that sorry countries around the globe
including those that have lower incomes
in the european union
can receive doses it is um the european
union
that of course does not mean that it is
an easy undertaking
because of all the manufacturing issues
that exist and we know this which is why
the commission is working on mechanisms
which anna has described to you here
in terms of uh mechanisms to help
share vaccine doses when when they are
made available uh to eu member states
but quite frankly i would address that
question perhaps to other parts
of the world and now we move to james
crisp
um thank you eric i hope you can hear me
could you please tell me which other
parts of the world you would address
that to
um also if it's not vaccine nationalism
is it vaccine protectionism and finally
i don't
think i caught your answer to lawrence's
question about how similar the
astrazeneca
agreement is to the cure-back deal thank
you very much
well on the last one i invite you to go
and look at
the um at the recording we just made of
my previous answer we're not going to be
repeating answers here
we have 20 minutes left on the first
part the key point is as i said
that europe is
working and has been working since the
beginning
on playing a major role in
helping countries with lower incomes
than
european union countries to get access
to the vaccine
to whom james wants to address his
question is his own business
oliver
yes hello on arsenica uh is it correct
to assume
that you took the assurances of the
company and or the other companies that
they have
proper sufficient production for the
facilities at face
value so basically you signed the
agreement with them
and then you had no means of checking
whether actually
they're up and running and then secondly
you said yourself about
you said 20 minutes ago about 20 minutes
ago you said
transparency is key so when are you
finally going to make the astrazenec
agreements
public so that we have clarity about
what's in the contract
thank you oliver your second question
you know very well that i said that
transparency on exports is key so that
we are in a position
uh to know what is going on on the
contracts
we have explained here time and time
again uh what our position
is uh so i'm not going to repeat it for
the hundredth uh for the hundreds
time on your first question let me
remind you that
the strategy which the commission is
rolling out
with the member states is a strategy
that has taken off actually very quickly
we started negotiating contracts
advanced purchasing agreements with
these companies and in the summer of
last
year and then the these contracts were
signed
over many months some of them are still
quite
quite recently sorry these advanced
purchasing agreements and then member
states
have started placing uh placing orders
and in the meantime we have had the
steering board
um which has met regularly to see how
things are
are going so we are following things
very very closely
and we are trying to make sure that
we take the necessary steps in order to
ensure that the companies
respect their obligations but as i've
said here before
this is this was never going to be
an easy ride this is a process that the
world has never embarked on before
developing in such a short space of time
less than a year a portfolio of vaccines
and then developing the production
capacities
in order to deliver hundreds
and hundreds of millions of doses
so of course there are issues which are
arising and of course
the commission and the member states
together are
in discussion with the member states in
order to try to
uh to solve them and the space of time
that has happened
since we first engaged with these
companies is actually extremely short
[Music]
[Music]
is
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
just two quick questions if i may the
first one
is on astrazeneca because if i
understand correctly
the issue is that astrazeneca is
delivering
the quantities of vaccine which were
promised
for the first quarter to the uk and not
to the
eu are you trying to get a a balance i
mean
if there are production issues it's
unfair that the
e just the you bears the burden of this
and the second one is always on
astrazeneca
uh i wonder what kind of
means of pressure do you have on
astrazeneca because
the commissioner kiriakidus yesterday
was very tough in his
in her declarations but actually the
share price in london is going up
so the effect was not very heavy
i wonder what kind of pressure can you
apply on the company thank you
tommaso let me um let me dispel
a misunderstanding here right from the
outset
our um dialogue
with astrazeneca has nothing to do
with uh trying to put the company
under pressure on financial markets uh
this is uh really something that is
absolutely no of our concern
our concern is the health of eu citizens
and it is the fact that um we need
uh hundreds of millions of doses of
vaccines from a whole series
of manufacturers in order to deliver on
this
and and so what we are doing is that we
are having frank
and very regular discussions with
astrazeneca
in order to make sure that the
information we have at
our disposal is clear
complete and allows us to find a way
forward
in order to get those doses and trust me
we will not let go until we are
in that position
that is on your second question on your
first question i passed the floor to
stefan
stefan please don't give up
i'm not in entirely clear i understand
um the purpose of the first question you
referred to deliveries
um to uh not to the eu but to
other to the uk quantities to the uk
that if there are production issues that
it would not be fair for the european
union to bear
the burden well i think um the
commission has
expressed not just a commission also the
the member states have expressed their
clear the dissatisfaction
with the announcements which had been
made by astrazeneca which
were about a very serious shortfall of
production this is not good
it's clear and this is why the strong
message has been passed by the
commission why we have
these discussions because we want that
indeed
deliveries that have been fixed in the
contract take place in a timely manner
so that we can
serve the european european citizens
secondly
in as also said before what helps here
what helps here
is to make sure that we have better
transparency about
what happened with the doses have they
been delivered where have they been
delivered and this is one of the reasons
why the commission called for the
establishment of this transparency
register
which will help to create much more
transparency here
in the interest of the commission and
member states in the interest of the
european citizens who are entitled to
receive
the doses that have been agreed upon in
the agreement thank you
and again let me stress i mean
the commission uh has from the outset
said that
we want vaccines to be available
not only in the eu but in the rest of
the world so this is not us
saying you know that somebody should not
be getting vaccines and that we should
be getting vaccines
that people in one country should not be
getting vaccines and we should be
getting vaccines
it's about making sure that the
companies
with which we have signed advanced
purchasing agreements
are delivering on their commitment they
have made to us
as well as on the commitments that they
have made to other countries
we don't contest that everybody of
course needs vaccines that's absolutely
clear
but what is absolutely certain as well
is that the european union has invested
these amounts of money in these
companies in order to make
sure that it is in a position
to receive the doses that it considers
necessary
for its vaccination campaigns and not at
any given point in time
but as soon as possible after the
conditional marketing authorization
has been delivered and this is what we
are what we are working on
and if we see of course that a company
is delivering
vaccines well we are perfectly entitled
to ask
why it is that suddenly it is told to us
that we cannot get
the quantities of vaccines that we have
ordered this is what the debate is about
and this is what the commission the
president means when he says europe
means business
okay we will take one last question i'm
sorry but then we will have to move over
we will have to move on sorry to the
press conference
david
[Music]
[Music]
uh
a
[Music]
[Music]
european
[Music]
who